let me jump to this uh next story it's
part of the same survey actually but
speaking of women ian oh yeah 2x
chromosomes have has this post
a study has found that a majority of
democrat men under 50 and a super
majority of republican men under 50
agree with the statement feminism has
done more harm than good boom keep that
in mind as we see roe falling femicide
increasing and birth control coming
under attack to little mainstream
fanfare i jump back to the same splc
poll that we had and i jump down to
gender identity
and they say
uh gender roles and gender identity
agreement that quote feminism has done
more harm than good
46
of young democratic men
that's the majority of young democrat
men saying more harm than good that one
was surprising
23 percent of young democrat women
unsurprising
52 percent of young republican women
think feminism has done more harm and 62
percent of young republican men think
it's done uh more harm that is not
surprising the republicans but the fact
that young democrat men think feminism
has done more har more harm
i would say is mostly surprising until
you factor in the fact that many of
those young democratic men are probably
in cells and i'm not saying that as a
pejorative and i'm not saying that uh to
drag them i'm saying literally there's
probably a large proportion of young men
in general regardless of political
affiliation who have not been able to
start a relationship or have sex and so
they blame feminism well the democrat uh
men are dating democrat women that's
exactly what they're merely gonna be the
feminists so they're the ones that are
probably when they're when they reach 30
and that's what happened to me that was
another part of my
i'm going i'm going on dates and i'm
getting lectured and told i'm a piece of
crap and i'm the problem and then the
check comes and i'm like and then you
know they just sit back and i go oh so
you just want the good parts yep of
feminism and that i found that across
the board and eventually i'm like well
i'm out sorry oh yeah i've had i've had
dates in my life where it was obvious
that chick just wanted dinner oh yeah
strong feminists just wanted dinner yeah
well they got it they got a uh oh but
i'll fuel up but i've i've always been
about gender equality so i just always
split the bill yeah yeah and the bill
comes and they would be like thank you
and i'd be like yeah you can you want to
do your card or should we do two cards
or what you want to do and they're like
wait what normally what are you thinking
here dude the last person i dated she uh
she insisted i pay every time and i
started to just feel like a sugar daddy
you know
uh but then she got a responding kind
like it's like the dude from mad men you
know yeah she's like all right babe come
on you know well they're they're picked
yeah they're kind of pick and choose the
best traits of feminism and uh
i mean you know good on them i'd do that
you know if i could i understand if i
could get a free meal paying for the
woman and her food and her comfort if
she's raising the child because you need
her body to be comfortable see that's
where you run into the problem because
me and this uh person she was going for
her career full force and i was going
for mine i'm
the breadwinner you know uh and so we
came to this point it's like well she's
not gonna stop and i'm not gonna stop so
we're never gonna settle down but i'm
gonna keep paying and then eventually
it's like well how long's it's like how
long is that going to last
say you're a chimpanzee yesterday yes
what say you're a chimpanzee full of
snakes it's like you're a chimpanzee
full of snakes you really said that yeah
he really said it and you're going to
rescue your father from the belly of a
win
oh yeah yeah
that's a pinocchio one
he's been a huge influence on me he was
one of the first people i heard talking
about this stuff and i would literally
cry watching being like
wow i can actually talk about this yeah
that's why he got so big he was like a
father figure to a lot of people oh my
god
changed my life i mean like i got into
therapy got into 12 steps and i i
went from broke to making six figures to
speaking out to you know this is a kid's
suit but it's still a suit
and
and and it's one per from one person
yeah from one person he would tell you
that others he's inspired of course by
others that came before him of course he
sums everything up so in layman's terms
that's his masterful skill he takes all
of this stuff and he puts it in plain 12
rules for life i want to point out this
feminism thing there's a really good
point that the feminists actually made
if you look at support older democrat
women older democrat men
tend to disagree with the statement they
think feminism did more good
and older republican women are 50 are
similar to young republican women but
older republican men 42 percent they
made a good point they said the older
generation probably views feminism more
as the right to vote yes and the younger
generation views it as like the
relationship black lives matter burning
down buildings it's a second generation
feminism which is from the 60s which is
the revolution the the
all that stuff suffrage i think might
have been the first generation and now
we're at 12th dimensional feminism where
no it's it's a super the whole ideology
exists in a superposition of itself it
does where everything is offensive and
inoffensive and you never know which
word you're allowed to say it's true
yeah well remember remember when we had
richie's mom on and she did not
understand like what was the issue with
feminism now and i was like it's not
like it was when you were dealing with
it because she's 60 something and it's
totally different now than it was when
she was looking at it like i understand
having a positive view of feminism when
it was actually seeking equality for
women with men that's totally different
no one disagrees with that exactly you
know about equality of opportunity but
it didn't seek to make women equal like
like the same as men in society's eyes
that was never you know this is the
crazy thing because it's like
do you think if you ask the average
female
do you feel safe walking alone in a dark
alley at night
they'd probably tell you to a greater
degree than men that they do not feel
safe and a guy might be like i don't
know i never i mean yeah i probably feel
a little unsafe but most guys might be
like i never thought about it for
obvious reasons guys tend to be bigger
tend to have more muscle mass and have
more bone density tend to have more skin
collagen or literally do
and
typically are less concerned about these
things women are typically more
concerned about these things
i i think it is probably jordan peterson
brought this up but
you if you want to figure out the
differences between men and women you
just tell everyone to line up from
shortest to tallest
and then it happens well it doesn't help
me much
how tall are you well i literally had to
change my height to millimeters on
tinder just to trick women
if you change your posture
2 000 millimeters
this is this is
a millimeter this is true when they they
added a height uh requirement or a
height like um in between you can go
your highest and lowest height of course
all chicks are gonna be like six seven
no one's going down to five two so i
actually don't show up in people's
matches anymore and my matches went down
almost to zero wow
yeah sucks i was fixing my posture and
elongating it and i gained about an inch
and a half perfect yeah
what also helps is um
getting uh
quartered drawn and quartered but not to
the point where they rip your limbs off
just to the point where you scream right
it's really scratched and quartered you
don't really know wrong just scored they
call it scoring the muscles
or they do this thing where they'll
break your legs
and then pull it a half inch that's a
good one and then the bones heal
so mia farrow did that to um uh uh ronan
farrow
yeah that's true definitely frank
sinatra's she really did that oh yeah
that's not that's not a joke yeah yeah
she really did that yeah yeah yeah she
did the changes
yeah what yeah that's true so he has
like really long legs and like a small
torso yeah yeah and you know
that's you know what what she didn't
know what he's talking about
i just like really long arms yeah you
play basketball yeah slenderman
i actually have a really like do you
have a long torso uh no moderate i have
a long torso moderator so when i'm at a
bar i i would meet women at bars and we
would be you know looking it should be
six feet she'd think i'm her height
she'd get up and she'd just keep getting
up and i would be here and one time i
met a woman on a train and i had a coat
over my legs we hit we talked for two
hours on the metro north she was six two
and i'm five three and she got up and i
just go i gotta cram i go just go go out
without
my goal would be to get back to her
house with her never seeing my legs wow
you know like i'm in the uber already
like let's go away just sounds like
you're doing some height equity in your
life yeah you do yeah yeah yeah height
privilege high
just put your pants in from knee first
and so then when they see you it just
looks like you're you know like a
wounded vet or something
and then you get up and just you know
get in the wheelchair and then yeah i
got my little service labradoodle dog
swimming you go swimming
stolen valor no you don't do that you're
already in the pool when they get there
yeah yeah
yeah
but height is height is a huge
determination for for um success yep
absolutely let me tell you guys let me
just sit i'm gonna ask you guys a
question i mean i'm people here's the
funny thing i took a picture with
charlie kirk and vosh and like was it
charlie like six five yeah he's really
tall bosh is like six three
and they're like they come over and
they're like let's get a picture
together i'm like okay and then i look
at the picture and i'm like dude it
makes me look like i'm five feet tall
like a toddler so it's it's funny though
because the way we have the cameras set
up yeah people whenever i meet them
they're like i thought you'd be shorter
you know interesting yeah because here's
how it works
typically when you watch a tv show or a
movie the people tend to look taller
because the cameras are held at chest
height right so from your perspective
perspective then you you're you're
imagining your head is the camera and
you're seeing these people that are tall
so when we have the cameras slightly at
head height and slightly going down
because we have to cross over each other
the people watching
feel like they're looking down at us and
so the assumption is they must be
shorter than me yeah when in reality
it's just the position of the camera
relative to where they were now that you
blew it man now they know i wonder if
that creates an air of like
a lack of authority from us because we
seem smaller
maybe i'll tell you let me tell you guys
something let me ask you a question
i used to work in uh street canvassing
non-profits this i'll i'll ask you tyler
yeah i did too actually by the way you
did for charter schools yeah oh cool so
you like walking people and you were
like hey can you give me money yeah well
i was actually i had i broke into the
trump towers this this is a true story
they'd have to sneak in but go ahead so
circle back there were two
characteristics that guaranteed a there
there uh there's one characteristic per
gender each gender has a specific
characteristic that guaranteed they
would do well in fundraising do you know
what that characteristic was for men
height yes had to be yeah so in my
experience working these non-profits for
some reason a good pen yes
the guys who came back typically always
having tons of donations were just tall
and there were some guys who you'd say
were dumb as a box of rocks
couldn't talk their their their way out
of a gas station and they were just
making money and i'm like what do you
say to people and they'd be like oh i
just told them like look you know you
got to give money you know and then they
do and i'm like well this six foot seven
guy
talking to people people just do it
scary
of the guys that tended to be more
successful and were short they talked
fast and matter-of-factly i like have no
idea what you're talking about nobody
knows what the hell you're talking about
tim yeah now now among women what do you
think the one trait was
that was more frequent among those who
just tended to do really well in terms
of donations
hold on it's for tyler two ideas
i have two ideas too it's their
wait donations from men or women or
anybody well all i know is
people would come back
and i would tend to see
tall guys would make consistent amounts
of consistent or large amounts of money
and then there was a characteristic
among women that these women would tend
to come back and just have money i hate
to say it but
boo i'm gonna say boobs i'm gonna go and
i'm gonna say boobies that is that is
true yeah that's correct well you can't
take that clip if i'm doing trump's
voice intelligence uh you you tended to
see it's not absolute yeah but women
with large breasts would tend to be like
it was easy
i i you know i got five donors and you
know and tall guys yeah we're animals
right we are animals yup and you can't
you can't
separate that from any from these
conversations all of them are it's our
primal instinct but you know what's
funny is the stigma around saying
women's breasts versus a man's height
like men can't control their height
you know what i mean women can't control
their boob size it's it's it sucks in my
opinion that both
you know there's these these determinate
factors yes we can that change right in
your chair
this is me at a bar
i
but but uh there's there's a uh uh
people are more worried to say is it is
it boobs yeah i was nervous i love but
he cares about saying a dude's type
people people can like these these women
can outright be like i won't date short
guys but if a dude says he's like i
don't date flat chicks they'd be like
how dare you i think genetic realism is
massively important part of the
conversation modern society absolutely
it doesn't get enough attention i'd like
it to get more
guys viscerally attracted to women with
large boobs so they want to be
physically near them literally they want
the opportunity maybe her hands going to
touch his hand when he's signing the
paper girls like tall guys because they
have large you know members and
everything or there's an assumption or
racial genetics like someone might have
a darker skin tone because the more
melanin from their ancestors getting
more sunlight things like that i love
that stuff yeah i mean look when a man
looks at a woman we're looking at their
their uh waist to hip ratio to really be
like can she crank a couple babes out
that's right that's what we're doing
it's not that we like big butts we like
to know that they can have kids well the
reason that people like big butts is
because it means that you are likely to
be a better
mother yeah like to be able to have
children more easily and nurse them
that's right exactly yeah butt fat is
associated with health as well okay yeah
it's much it's much better than um
abdominal fat i think the communists
they hate the idea that there is an
element of your life they can't control
yeah right but i always tell people like
look man you can't change the cards you
were dealt but you can you can play your
hand the best of your abilities i've
seen some poker hands where dude's got
seven two off suit but bluffs his way
into winning the pocket yeah i want to
turn him with the jack six when the
blinds are high and it's every hand
house uh counts you can you can win with
a crappy hand she's got not a player
he's gotta know how exactly yeah yeah
you can't change the direction of the
wind but you can adjust your size oh
it's motivational i think short guys are
funnier because that was my that was my
way to get women's attention it was be
the funniest person probably talk the
fast fastest and uh you know so i i see
like a tall guy looks like me he's
really hot i'd go if i was him i
wouldn't be funny at all you could do it
lord farquaad did remember that when he
had the knight's armor but it was like
his feet went into the massive metal
legs
someone said what i'm doing with my
pants right now
suits yeah well i mean it was a comedy
fantasy film so yeah the military's
working on giant exo suits where you can
lift like 10 000 pounds i don't know how
much weight they get but they're like a
thousand pound suits the dude was just
on rogan talking about it damn wow we
still require battery packs we're
talking about building a real-life iron
man suit like that's what the military
is working on right now have you guys
seen obi-wan the show no no i started
watching it even though i was like i
don't like star wars and it's exactly as
bad as you think it is oh no
it's basically just like
remember darth vader
remember obi-wan
it's just like okay did we get it you're
just telling us what we assumed happened
anyway but i bring it up because they
actually show darth vader and like his
limbs are cut off and then he like
you know they attach the things to his
body or whatever
and then you know it is kind of cool
actually to actually see darth vader
going about his business because you
only have the big movie moments right
anyway is james earl jones to doing the
voice still yes he is wow
but um you know i just bring it up
because he had
limbs like he had his prosthetics so you
know he's short but you know now he's
tall
yeah that's a good point everyone's got
a thing everyone's got a thing that that
they suffer from and it's like that that
that's back to the race thing where it's
like you have no idea what anybody's
going through when i was a kid my best
friend was black his grandfather was the
chief of police so the police department
was run by a black family and i wanted
to be him so bad
you know my parents were getting
divorced my dad came out of the closet
life was hell my mom was suicidal and
it's like i wanted to be my black friend
more than anything and it's like
nowadays i feel so bad for these kids
who are going to be born and they are
they're going to go well i have it worse
even though my life is hell just because
i'm
on black or white or vice versa yeah i
think that the damage this is going to
do to children is going to be like just
irreversible it was stark when i heard
that for the first time i don't know it
was probably about four years ago that
because of your skin color things will
be harder that really bothers or easier
yeah yeah like you tell a five-year-old
that they're gonna believe my life is
hard and then they're going to start
finding problems
to justify what they think yeah
especially in this victimhood uh society
where it's like a billion dollar
business now so
it's so tragic yeah this is something
let's talk about pharmaceuticals for a
second but i totally missed the ball on
that speech he just gave not talking
about pharmaceuticals with kids what do
you think biden's intention is to sell
more to pharmaceuticals
this is why i say he's a bad person this
is why i call him evil he lied
he is trying to manipulate people to so
so they give up their rights
and he's not addressing actual issues
that are screwing people over
i mean you look at these people
in in government and they're just like
what can i do today to screw over
regular people because i want power
and like they're
do you think they're working towards
some sort of profit motive well let me
let me ask you something right let me
ask you guys a question what if the
earth really is overpopulated and
climate change is about to wipe us out
if that were true would you support
taxing gas shutting down pipelines
suspending air travel locking people
down no no ramp it up i'm not gonna kill
myself to stop the problem that's not
the way to stop the problem go out with
a bang anytime let's say yeah yeah so
you would say if you knew that we were
like let's just say like hypothetically
six months to the apocalypse unless
everything was shut down now you'd say
bring on the apocalypse
after covet i think if cova didn't
happen that the the lockdowns i'd say
yeah but after that like no i'm not
going through that again i can't do it
nope it's inevitable
there's nothing i don't think that
there's anything functionally that we
could do to actually stop an apocalypse
if it's really that predictable and that
evident that it's coming
there's nothing to break up with her
i think they're lying and here's what i
say
if you seed control to these people when
they come out and they scream this the
sky is falling
they're probably wrong
they're just probably wrong
uh they might be right science might say
a lot of things but we are but humans we
are not you know omniscient we're not
gods so i can respect when they say
things like we better be better stewards
of the earth and i'll be like okay i'm
down let's do green energy because that
makes sense
but when you seed power to them and
they're like
suspend population growth which leads to
cultural collapse and civilizational
stagnation and potential collapse when
they say things like they're going to
sacrifice x many people by shutting down
fuel and and you know pipelines and
stuff that's going to result in death
i'm like and if you're wrong
you're actually causing the problem you
are the apocalypse there's two ways to
look at it climate change is destroying
the planet there's too many humans or
we need more humans to continually
expand our scientific understanding
decentralized uh
the decentralized power among the people
will find a solution to these problems
and carry humanity beyond the stars
i i lean in that direction there's no
there's also there's a i forget who it
was on rogan two guys i think who wrote
a book about
population and they said
what's your evidence that the earth is
overpopulated what do you what's the
number it's it's the same thing with
cover there's no limiting factors is it
9 billion 10 50
it's not that it's overpopulated it's
just that we're not properly dealing
with the resources right and i've never
heard anyone say that until until those
two guys and it kind of blew my mind a
little bit yeah so when billy uh we're
too heavily organized in cities and
reliant on the outskirts of the farms
like if the power goes out and the roads
get blocked the cities get starved
that's the problem that's one of the
hugest problems
decentralized communities with magnetic
trains where you can just travel that's
circular cities ruled by supercomputers
like burning man is that why they're
letting everyone get shot in new york
city maybe that's just like they're
letting it get shot
when bill gates bill gates comes out and
he gave a ted talk where he said that
you know we can reduce population growth
by 10 or 15 percent
here's a guy who says we need less
people and what if he's wrong what if we
need more people what if elon musk is
right
pick one you know this this idea when
they come out and they're like we're
overpopulated in climate change and i'm
just like
and if you're wrong
so i i look at this way humans have
continually adapted more people means
more innovation
let's
make a bet on humanity and not
against humanity yeah the connection is
we the people are poorly organized the
amount of people we have right now and
the organization structure that they're
in is not sustainable if if the power
goes out and the roads get blocked
people will have a mass die off in the
cities but it's also true that we need
more people so we need a more organized
structure for those people better travel
better transport drone delivery of food
things but we do these things humans
develop these things you know we adapt
to these issues well the whites are
dying out guys i know what you're
complaining about it's all we need 10
years and we're fine oh that's that's a
funny thing too about um white people
becoming a minority because it's like
it's white liberals that aren't having
kids you know what i mean yeah and
that's also assuming like people are
getting together that aren't the same
race because if a white person and a
mexican person get together and have a
baby the baby's not considered white
exactly
so that that's actually how the census
works in this country if a white person
has a kid with someone who's half white
the baby is just not white even though
it's a quarter you know whatever race
yeah you just considered other
interesting yeah but they could grow up
and be called white adjacent well that's
a that's a political thing i mean like
as far as it goes with at least this is
what i was
what it was like growing up they said
you're not considered to be solely white
for me because i have you know asian so
it was just like you're not a white
person you got asian yeah can i buy it
can i what can i get i want to pay you
for that man uh i i would have to
extract you an offer dude 25 of myself
it's like yeah haven't they won every
white guy i know does not want to be
white it's like okay you want you guys
won
every white guy's like i wish i had
something that i can just add to my
resume right now i was raised by a gay
man and his partner and i'm like that i
wish that transferred but those credits
don't transfer you know i'm gay raised i
wish i no because it's not my lived
experience that's that's what i'm told
but you've got insight into the lived
experience yeah i grew up in gay bars
but it doesn't matter it's like no one
wants to hear it
interesting
well because erased because i'm white
that's right yeah even gay there's a lot
of gay white men now who are getting uh
rejected in hollywood and they're
reaching out to me that's i'm like damn
we've really it's bad yeah not gay
enough or not you know like not quite
dark enough oh yeah that's the best
thing it's like
if uh if i come out and agree with them
then i'm a marginalized person if i
disagree with them well you're white
it's like oh so i get to be white if i
disagree with you yeah okay
let me tell the racists over there who
who you know what you said give me
permission to be white that's why i
think that whole ideology is just
bankrupt it's so it's
destructive it's i think it's the number
one thing that'll destroy the country i
got to say though this what is a woman's
stuff uh the wokeness
it's a great red pill when
what is a woman is the best question
because you you're seeing all these
progressives
unable to answer it and then i'm just
like man
all you got to do is go you're like how
do i convince my parents or whatever
asking what a woman is
there you go
that's terrifying it's like a simple
dictionary question and it's funny it's
it's like people can't answer it well
how can you fight for women's rights and
then not be able to define that's the
thing that everything is starting to
contradict itself the house of cards is
just falling down they've got they've
created they've made up so many terms
and
ideas they're starting to collapse it's
fun to watch i think that's what i
thought the uh the flag was the pride
flag there was so many flags on a flag
that it was collapsing on itself
it didn't have like um structure the
structure was lost in the madness it's a
perfect representation it's madness they
want it to be madness
that what the the thing that nets posted
where it was just like it it looked like
a jackson pollock painting yeah it was
just weird symbol symbols and shapes and
lines and i'm like
that's what i'm talking about that was
the house of a house of flags is that
what this is the new jersey nets is that
we're talking about brooklyn or the
brooklyn nets yeah and it was like this
weird do we have that one
a couple nights ago it's a great fight
oh you're from brooklyn oh yeah yeah i
live in brooklyn now yeah i'm sorry
brutal yeah here we got it we got it
right here like yo that's it i even saw
gay guys who were just like i don't
understand what this is it's too crazy
what is it it's too many people trying
to be accepted for something that's
different
and now that's k that's chaos in action
right there well they're justifying
every new made-up group and then they
have to give the new one there color or
space on the flag there's going to be
that this is going to multiply every
year of course that's so wild it's got a
like it feels like it's collapsing on
itself from the chaos we should make a
flag yeah
what kind of flag i don't know
but everyone else has one i kind of want
one i definitely want one they should
make a flag for biden
trump's got a flag
the biden one could be him sniffing some
glass of milk a glass of milk pudding
applesauce
a glass of milk
yeah that's it dog it says dog face yeah
i love dog facebook
could you make like a flag that's a
prism so depending on how you look at it
you might see the rainbow or you might
you just might see through it a
three-dimensional flag yeah a cube yes
they gotta stop giving people flags and
parades
it's ke it's it's making these people
turn into children
it's gotta stop i'm not i'm just not
celebrating it anymore i mean i used to
have to because i grew up right you know
i think we should just give out one
quote a flag with their name on it yeah
yeah because the smallest minority is
the individual that's right right
there you go and the smallest individual
is a baby that's right we should carry
the most babies so we should make flags
for unborn children that's right yes i
want to arm them that might solve the
birth certificate problem you know with
the assignments the birth assignment the
gender assignments at birth you just get
a flag instead of a gender assignment
perfect you get a selfie they make a
problem picture of it with it in your
hand no names anymore just say yes
yep perfect oh yeah back in the day
before they had addresses they had
shapes and images on every house like
there would be a red shield you know
rothschild the rothschild that means red
shield came from the original guy at a
red shield in this house we're
regressing back to that shapes and
symbols and emojis
i love it it's like hieroglyphics yeah
that's a good idea i love it i wonder if
i could do that you know like we'll
build a house and then when we have to
register with the post office i'll be
like it's the poop emoji house
they're like we're not running this
herd's
i wonder if we could do that that'd be
funny you can you can actually create
streets so there was a property i was
looking at and there was this like
gravel road that just went off the side
and the owner said that
uh he he like sold it to the city or
whatever but he it already had a name
and so it just became like the name
street they left it the way it was and
i'm like so we could we could do that
because i'll create a crazy named street
you know like you know like amber turd
avenue or something yeah hill hill
hill road but it would be a hill you
know hill road
hill hills for buying grover
hill hill
[Laughter]
if you had a city would you name stuff
after yourself if i had a city
uh yeah for branding i think i think
it's a good branding i would too at this
point yeah absolutely could you imagine
like you it's it's the 1600s and you you
just you walk up a hill and you're like
i'm gonna build the house right here
and then they'd be like what's that
place over there and like oh that's
iansberg
because berg is hill right and then he'd
be like oh and then you'd be like yep
i'm in that's my hill and then everyone
started calling it ian's berg and then
now it's iansberg and then now we have
that
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you